oh magazine it is undergoing some big  changes starting with the end  of a 20-year cover tradition but for a  very good reason  we've never done anything like this  before after appearing on the cover  of every issue for 20 years oprah is now  giving that honor to brianna taylor  the 26 year old emt who was killed by  police during a raid of her kentucky  home  this was my way our way to o magazine  of honoring her celebrating her life and  the lives of  every other woman black woman in  particular whose  life has been taken unfortunately too  soon  if it were not for covid i would be  marching in the streets  oprah also announced that december 2020  will be the magazine's last monthly  issue  in print as they explore going more  digital  oprah told us i look forward to the next  step in our evolution  you